JONAH BERGER: I can't thank
you enough, actually, for
spending time on this because,
obviously, you don't have to
be a great lover of the news
to sort of wonder why would
anyone be talking about startups
in the Middle East
with what's going on right now
here in Syria, and Egypt, and
that kind of stuff.
But I can tell you from my
experience, and the journey
that I've been on to see what's
been going on on the
ground, it's actually the
perfect time to be
talking about it.
Because there's a phenomenon
that you guys know very well,
but a lot of people don't know
very well, about how
technology has unleashed
incredibly powerful things.
I don't want to take away one
iota of the seriousness of
what's happening here because,
obviously, we know
how serious it is.
And I can tell you that there
are entrepreneurs that I know,
amazing entrepreneurs who I met
in Damascus and in Cairo,
who died in the last
couple of weeks.
So it's a very, very
real thing.
I'm not going to be talking
about here's something nobody
knows about-- it's the only
thing that matters.
Both matter, both co-exist,
but it's
something very powerful.
I'm not an expert in the
Middle East, per se.
So one of things I can't do is
tell you what's going to
happen in the next six months,
or what's going to happen next
three years.
But what I can tell you with
pretty close to 100%
certainty, which you guys, I
think, live in a very powerful
way, is that in three years
there's going to be a lot more
technology in a lot more
people's hands.
And there isn't any scenario I
see where that's going away.
Marc Andreessen wrote the
forward to my book, and he
wrote it how we are moving,
within the next 8 to 10 years,
to a world of 5 billion
smartphones.
And that almost becomes
a throwaway now.
Eric Schmidt's used five billion
people with broadband.
I mean, everyone sort of throws
it out as kind of a
rough number.
But it doesn't cease to amaze
me, whether it's in
Washington, in politicians,
and investors, here in New
York, or in Silicon Valley rock
stars who've invented so
much of the stuff that the real
ramifications of what
that means is not as well
understood as one would hope.
And in fact, even the question
of what does a world of $5
billion smartphones look like is
not something that I think
a lot of people spend as much
time thinking about overall.
Broadly based, not in a
technology worlds like you
guys, I think that, in many
ways, folks just think they
are highfalutin telephones
or entertainment devices.
David Stern, who just is about
to step down as the head of
the NBA, is actually going to
retire from the NBA and travel
all over emerging markets
because he knows that a lot
more people are going to be able
to watch NBA games on a
going forward basis.
So there is that connectivity.
But what smartphones really
are, of course, is
supercomputing capacity, if Mark
is right, in the hands of
2/3 of humanity.
And I could tell you among the
mobile providers that I've met
throughout the Middle East,
most of them thought that
Egypt would have 50% smartphone
penetration in the
next two years.
In the Gulf right now,
it could be 80%
in places like Dubai.
And you're just going to see,
I think, an incredibly
powerful world.
Internet penetration is
unbelievable there right now.
There are huge per
capita incomes.
Unlike Turkey, which is a
fantastic ecosystem of
startups, it is actually a
very large market of Arab
speakers around the region.
350 million.
Their location is just
unbelievable, North, South,
and East and West.
And so, in some respects, it's
not surprising that in that
kind of locale, even with the
political instability,
something incredibly powerful
will happen when people have
access to computing technology
and can begin to bottom up, do
things in terms of innovation
and problem solving, which
would have been unimaginable
in the narrative
that we have there.
My journey, just quickly to
share it with you, I've run
several internet companies.
I've outsourced technology
to pretty much every
corner of the Earth.
I've traveled all
over the world.
And I've even been to the Middle
East as a tourist.
But my narrative has been so
strong in terms of one view of
the Middle East, and the Arab
world in particular, that it
really did not fit my thinking
that, in the early days of my
journey, Mubarak's Egypt or
Saudi Arabia would really have
a technology ecosystem at all.
I knew about Israel.
I'd outsourced to Israel.
But I just couldn't get it in
my mind, despite all my
experience in outsourcing
technology to so many parts of
the world, that, of course, it
would be happening in the Arab
world as well.
In 2010, I was invited by some
very dear friends of mine
who'd been talking about the
ecosystem to one of the first
large gatherings of startups in
the Middle East, or in the
Arab world, called celebration
of entrepreneurship.
And, in many respects, my view
of the world I think of as
before and after that event.
Because it was 2,400 young
people, from North Africa to
Yemen, 2,000 person
waiting list.
Nobody really wanted to
talk about Israel.
Nobody cared about Obama's
Cairo speech.
These are guys you
know, right?
And women that you know.
I mean, that's the other thing
that surprises everyone.
Almost every gathering that I
go to, and now studies have
backed it up, 35%,
40% are women.
And you'd feel completely at
home in these events, and in
the problem solving, and the
challenges that they were
thinking about.
And it just made me wake up to
my own stuckedness in the
narrative that I have
and made me start to
think about the world.
I expanded that trip and started
traveling around
Cairo, and Amman, and other
places where I'd
heard it was real.
And I just saw it over, and
over, and over again.
And I got called back to be a
judge of a startup competition
in January of 2011.
And again, from all over Egypt,
these amazing young
people building amazing
things.
In fact, one of my favorites
was a guy who kept talking
about this great, highest paid--
he said it was the
highest paid weather
app in the world.
And I looked down at my, forgive
me, I have an iPad.
But I looked down at my iPad.
And I had downloaded it six
month previous, and had no
idea that it was 30 young people
in Alexandria, Egypt
who had build it.
And I'd paid $0.95 for
it, or what have you.
But when that was over,
I went to Damascus.
And when I was there, I saw,
again, these unbelievable
young people.
And that's when Ben Ali of
Tunisia left Tunisia and left
the country.
And it just changed the
entire dynamic.
And when I got back to Cairo
to fly back to the United
States, I could just see all
young people are saying, this
is something big.
This is bigger than us.
And of course, every one of
the entrepreneurs I met, a
week later, were out in Tahrir
Square, changing everything
that happened overall.
So that's it.
I was hooked.
It's a different thing
about the world.
And it's an obvious place where
the world is going.
And the caliber of the kids that
are building stuff in a
world where the ecosystem, which
I'll come back to in a
moment, is really a bottom
up ecosystem.
I mean, the infrastructure
of education, government
supporting this, is, to
be kind, the minimus.
The headwinds that these young
entrepreneurs are really important.
But again, if you have
ubiquity of access to
broadband technology,
mobile devices, you
just build stuff anyway.
And in every country that I've
seen, they've done it in the
most powerful way.
The kind of startups that I've
seen, I'd bucket them in the
book into three categories.
And they'd all be familiar to
you based on the things that
you use, overall.
The first is also
very familiar in
emerging markets generally.
I call them the improvisers.
They're often called, elsewhere,
copycats, which I
think is uncharitable because
I think these companies have
done an amazing amount of effort
not just to merely take
that which has worked in the
West and bring it here, but
they're incredibly sensitive to
the dynamics of the region
and unique needs
to it overall.
But as you know, Baidu in
China, and e-commerce
companies in Brazil,
and everywhere.
It's not surprising that in
risky environments, people
take something that's already
worked and ameliorate some of
the risk by customizing
it to the market.
So Matu was a Yahoo of the
Middle East, which was bought
by Yahoo for almost $200 million
a couple of years ago.
Souk.com, MarkaVIP are these
juggernauts of e-commerce
which would look very familiar
to you, to Amazon and that
kind of stuff.
There's a WebMD of
the Middle East.
There are probably 20 of them.
And they're doing
very, very well
they've raised some capital.
They've been very successful.
And they've been scaling
in powerful
ways across the region.
The second category of people
that really have almost blown
me away personally, as much as
from looking at it from a
business perspective, I call
the problem solvers.
And these are folks who look
at these infrastructure
challenges, and where guys my
age or older say, oh, it's
going to take a generation to
fix it, and the governments
are too fucked up to figure
out how to do it, they're
like, we'll solve it.
It is an area that we're in
that I see in startups who
pitch me here.
And it's something that's
amazing to watch in emerging
growth markets, which is to
look at infrastructure
problems and software
problems.
So traffic is terrible.
People say, well, you've
got to fix the roads.
Well, you've got to
fix the roads.
But that doesn't mean that
they're not ways, like
navigation devices and crowd
sharing, that allow people to
navigate traffic the way they
never could before.
Garbage and recycling is in its
infancy, to be generous.
And again, amazing young people
from all over the
region who are saying, I've got
a great idea to build a
platform where people
know where to
deliver their garbage.
And I'll figure out a way
to send to China.
Because then I'll make
some money on it.
And we can get the garbage clean
while building a really
great green company.
We can do amazing things and
solve that problem overall.
As you can imagine, there's
just amazing
amounts of sun there.
So solar, there are unbelievable
ideas.
Not just big infrastructure in
solar, but really kind of
basic, small use, like in
agriculture and cities, which
are really very powerful.
And I'm going to come back
to that in a second.
But it's very moving.
Probably the most moving of all,
because it is, in many
respects, the biggest challenge
of that the region
faces, is an education.
I was very surprised to find,
when I was over there, that,
actually, a significant
amount of
money is spent on education.
But it is almost invariably
the wrong education--
very heavy on rote learning.
Particularly in the poorer
parts of some of these
regions, there could be a
classroom of 70 kids with not
really any discipline.
They're all taught to tests, but
the tests are pretty much
for the 20th century, not for
the 21st century and all.
So this is a very, very
significant infrastructure
issue that pays a multiplier
price, as you
guys know so well.
And again, if you're in
your 20s, you say,
well, that's terrible.
So I'm going to hack
the system.
And the number, probably in
Egypt, 15% of the startups
I've seen have been some form
of use of video or other
social capacities, even at the
texting level, where people
could help tutor each other,
share each other course
curricular, and put
it up online.
And it's just been unbelievable
to watch.
And it's getting amazing
traction because Egypt alone,
in response to the problems with
education, Egypt alone is
somewhere between a $2 and $3
billion tutoring country-- $2
to $3 billion.
And as you can imagine, most
of the people who are
forwarding the tutoring are
pretty well heeled.
Well, all of the sudden, you
have these Khan Academies in
Arabic that are springing up all
over that are really not
charging anything for it.
And instead of the elite being
able to get tutoring to get
around a lousy system, if they
haven't already sent the kids
abroad somewhere, you now have
anybody, anywhere, who can get
ahold of it, share it, and do
really kinds of interesting
things with it.
And so it doesn't solve things
overnight, but most people
don't focus on it.
And it's just a very powerful,
powerful thing.
Third thing, the third
group of companies I
call the global players.
And they not unlike
the app guy that I
described to you before.
They know, as you all know,
we all know, the world is
literally a click away, which
means that, literally, women
at home who have little crafts
business that they used to
sell within their neighborhood
are now shipping
stuff around the world.
And larger, scalable businesses
are creating
really, really interesting
enterprises that allow them to
do manufacturing in Asia or sell
things on platforms all
over the world.
And so I've talked a lot about
difference of them as I've
been going about over
the last few months.
But there's this wonderful woman
from Beirut who is just
an awesome swimmer.
I mean just like college
grade college swimmer.
And it drove her crazy that
there really was not a great
way, while she was training,
to watch her vital signs.
Like most of the stuff, if any
of you guys are swimmers, you
know this, still now a lot of
ways you can do that is
devices that were for running,
then they adapted them to
being waterproof.
But if you're swimming, who
the hell wants to look at
their wrist to see
what's going on.
So she-- forgive the analogy--
but she build kind of a Google
Glass of goggles.
So it's a very smooth, very easy
thing, very streamlined.
And you could look up to it
and you can see your vital
signs in real time as it's
measuring off of your temple.
She's being manufactured
in China.
And it's big distribution
contracts now in the United
States, all done
out of Beirut.
She thought a globally
from the beginning.
She had a very local
need as a swimmer.
But she immediately said that,
in the age we live in now, we
can become global players in
very, very interesting ways.
I want to not blow smoke at you,
as generous hosts, and as
a shareholder, I admire
you guys greatly.
But I can tell you that in these
ecosystems, the value of
big technology players to have
an enormous impact is
unbelievable because, as I
suggested to you before, the
ecosystems really are still
unbelievably nascent.
They really are happening
autodidact, right?
There are all these wonderful,
wonderful, and some of them
enormous, conferences that
happen that gather people.
There are startup competitions
all the time.
There are startup weekend
all over the place.
The last Startup Weekend in the
Middle East, last weekend,
or the weekend before
was in Gaza--
Gaza.
Entrepreneurs in Gaza cut
through all the stuff that
they're dealing with and
said, we're going
to host this thing.
We're going to invite some
unbelievable entrepreneurs
from Jordan.
They are going to come here, and
we're going to make this
whole thing happen.
250 young people in Gaza showed
up to Startup Weekend.
So it's happening.
The education institutions are
beginning that significant
investment in technology and
infrastructure, particularly
in the Gulf.
Entrepreneurship programs
are building.
So there's something
in motion.
But there's a ways to go.
So when you have a group like
Google over there, it just
makes an unbelievable
difference.
An a lot of tech companies,
now, are doing this.
Though first and foremost,
they're obviously a sales
operation, which is completely
understandable.
But when you look at Google, if
you look at Paypal, if you
look at LinkedIn, they're all
doing what they're doing for
their businesses.
But they're saying, man, if this
ecosystem grows, we're
all going to help each other in
unbelievably powerful ways.
So Google Egypt was
a mine blower.
The guy who runs it is just an
amazing guy, very decent man,
very creative.
And they put together, two years
ago, this thing they
called Ebda2, which was the
first major startup
competition put on by a great
technology company anywhere in
the Middle East.
And this wasn't just a startup
competition, right?
They either bought or rented
buses and drove all over Egypt
to effectively evangelize about
entrepreneurship, and
startup, and tech.
So a lot of times, what happens
is people go to Dubai,
or people go to Amman, or they
go to Cairo, and Alexandria is
an amazing thing.
But no one goes to Tanta, which
is actually an amazing
engineering town, kind of a
little town two or three hours
outside, let alone to other
parts of the rural areas.
And the team at Google Egypt
literally just got in buses,
went around, had thousands of
people who came up with ideas
and competed.
And they had a big event in
Cairo and picked 5 or 10, I
can't remember, finalists.
And the winner, who got $250,000
or something, and
that's a lot of money for
the ecosystem there.
So it's about the money.
It's about awareness.
It's about helping
each other out.
It's about bringing people
together in physical ways.
And the multiplier effect of
that is hard to describe.
But you watch it happen.
And it's just wonderful.
It's a mind blow.
Investment money is still
pretty nascent.
I mean, the Middle East there's
been a tradition for
some time of sorts of private
equity-- in other words, a
cash flow business of a
certain size that you
can put money in.
There have been a few venture
capital firms
that have been there.
There have been some Western
venture capital firms,
certainly, who have dipped their
toes in Istanbul as a
platform for the region, but
others who are looking at it
in very powerful ways.
But, excitingly, in the last
two years, there has really
been a rise in angel investing--
so really, really
early stage stuff.
You've got kind of the
late exit stuff.
You've got the early,
early stuff.
What they're really struggling
on now is what we, here in the
states, call the A round.
So in other words, a company
may raise a couple hundred
thousands dollars.
They are starting to kick ass.
Things are looking good.
Now they need that one the two,
what would for us would
be three to five, maybe
one to two over there.
And where do you go?
And that's depressing if you're
ready to take off and
you have that thing.
And so they're coming.
They are building.
I know several multi $100
million funds that are being
raised solely for this.
They are a lot of main
companies, like
mobile players and all.
Vodafone is an example of this,
is actually funding now
in the early stage, but
moving to the A round.
So it's all happening in really,
really interesting
ways, despite the chaos that
is also very real and very
tragic at the same time.
That chaos cannot
be understated.
These amazing entrepreneurs
face real headwinds, and I
would suggest that any
entrepreneur in an emerging
growth market faces
headwinds, right?
It's not easy to do a
startup in India.
It's not easy, lord knows, to
do a startup and then to
repatriate capital in China.
Friends of mine who are
investors in Brazil have armed
guards when they go
to the movies.
I mean, emerging markets are
not for the faint of heart.
But as we all know that there's
an incredible rise of
middle class and an amazing
ability of technology for
people to see how each other
live and to share different
ideas and collaborate
in different ways.
It's not going back either.
So it's just a different kind
of mental outlook to the
challenges, knowing full well
that the top 10 guys, the guys
who are playing the 20th century
rules, like Syria, are
squashing what is really a
generational opportunity.
So both are true.
Both are to be considered.
But I think we, in the West,
tend to think about the bad
one, not about this hopeful
one as much.
I'll close with a very
interesting thing that, when
Benghazi happened--
our consulate was attacked,
and Chris was killed, and
three other people were killed,
and Cairo embassy was
attacked, I got a phone call
from a "New York Times"
journalist, who effectively
said to me, OK,
you're done, right?
I mean, you are going to stop
talking about this.
There's no way this is
ever going to happen.
And I said to him-- this is a
very smart, well-traveled guy,
knows more about the Middle
East than I'll know--
and I said, how many
people were
involved in those attacks?
And he said, I don't know, maybe
2,000, 3,000 people.
In a point of fact, it was
probably about 200.
And I said, look, I mean, these
attacks were terrible.
I knew the ambassador.
These are terrible.
But four months earlier, I was
in Beirut for the MIT startup
competition.
And it was 5,000 or 6,000
companies from all over Middle
East, 40% of them were women,
that represented 14,000 or
15,000 entrepreneurs.
And there ideas are
unbelievable.
And he just kind of froze
and said, well this is--
there's something else
that's going on.
And so in many respects, as I
thank you a lot for spending
time on what is a counter
narrative, I also know that
you know that this is where
the world is going.
That again, we know, in three
years, there's going to be a
lot more technology in a lot
more people's hands.
And the ramifications on
politics, on culture, on
society, on debates about
religion, about debates about
women's roles in society, and
about how people seize their
economic future, I don't think
it's ever going to go back.
Thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
JONAH BERGER: I would love if
you have any questions or,
more importantly, any thoughts
from your own
experiences, or--
AUDIENCE: So it's been
demonstrated in the past few
years that social technology
in particular can be very
disruptive to government
operations.
In Egypt, we saw that
with Twitter.
I was just wondering, as you've
seen entrepreneurship
develop in these regions, is
there any sort of effort by
the governments to stymie it, to
get in the way of it, or to
make it not as easy
to do stuff?
JONAH BERGER: So you're, in a
lot of respects, hitting what
is maybe the most important
dichotomy that one sees here,
and, I would suggest, across
emerging markets, which is
that, I think, at the end of the
day, so many governments
and regimes who rose in the days
of consolidating wealth
and power to a small minority
people in order to keep
control are trying to figure
out what do you do is
something which is so, by
definition, bottom up.
And to compound the point that
you're making, they really
think about it is a political
tool first and foremost.
So their idea is, if we can
just contain enough of the
free flow of political stuff, so
we can stay in power, then
all is going to be fine.
And maybe a few good things
will happen about and
everything else.
What so many of them miss, in my
view, is that it's not just
about the freedom of speech,
but this is the economic
force, platform,
of the future.
So that what you're doing is not
only constraining voice,
and trying to divvy out economic
gain, you're actually
constraining the entire way
folks compete in other parts
in the world.
And so folks--
I mean, I've had amazing,
interesting conversations with
folks who are much smarter
than I'll ever
be in emerging markets.
And they'll say, maybe,
governments can
pull that off, right?
Look, when I was in business
school, Tienanmen Square just
happened a couple years
before that.
Everyone said, look.
That's it.
They're done.
China will never be
anything now.
If you don't have political
liberalism, you'll never have
economic growth.
I mean, that was the
conventional wisdom then.
And obviously, despite their
political stuff, something
happened there.
So right, a lot of people
said maybe you
can have dual things.
My own belief is that you can.
This is not say a
paradox at all.
That you have an ability
in doing this
to constraint stuff.
It's one thing, maybe, if you're
a country driving 150
miles an hour to think, maybe,
you can take it down to 130 at
least for a period of time,
in control, maybe.
But the countries I'm dealing
with, a lot of them are going
40 miles an hour.
And if you take a generation
out, then I don't know
how you catch up.
So it's an unbelievably profound
choice compounded by
the fact that this generation
is more
mobile than ever before.
So at some point, they'll
say enough.
No mas.
The only thing that I can tell
you, despite everything I've
said, Syria is a perfect
example of this.
I just know literally
dozens of these
entrepreneurs who got out.
They are in Beirut now.
Or they are in Dubai.
And they can't wait
to go home.
And they just figure, the
governments will mess with us,
but we'll always find
a work around.
And so that's why I
remain hopeful.
But your question is the
central question that
constrains us in ways that
are-- it's a missed
opportunity is the thing
that's so frustrating.
AUDIENCE: Are there any leaders
in the Middle East, in
government, that you found are
more open to this idea?
It seems like Amman has been
developing somewhat as a tech
hub, and King Abdullah is
somewhat more open.
But at the same time, it
seems like a facade.
And I'm just wondering,
traveling, do you see that
there is, even if it's not
established leaders, that
there are people in power
that are looking to this
opportunity, and to actually
embrace it?
JONAH BERGER: I think the answer
is fundamentally no.
The King of Jordan is a very
remarkable guy and has been
backing the information
technology, from an
infrastructure basis, for
many, many years.
The talent that you see in
Amman, and the incubators
there will blow you away.
And you can't take it away
from his government in
thinking about that.
But at the same time, Jordan
passed some pretty tough news
rights and freedom of speech
rights stuff on the internet
that had a chilling effect on
a lot of young people there,
like I didn't think you were
going to do this, and now
you're doing it too.
Dubai has all the
infrastructure and all the wealth.
E-commerce is going to be an
enormous opportunity in the
Middle East in the next
couple of years.
And Dubai is a fantastic hub for
that, logistics as much as
anything else.
They've got their internet
crackdown stuff as well.
And so what I would say to you,
at least in the case of
the Emirates, at least in the
case of the King of Jordan, I
think they're doing
a balancing act.
They know that there's
something here.
This is not just lip service.
I don't believe it's
just lip service.
But they are in a tough
neighborhood, and they're
trying to balance that
in different ways.
And history will tell whether
they can pull off that balance
in a very, very powerful way.
But this is a golden opportunity
for some leader to
step up, and relate to this
generation, and see what
happens here.
The new head in Cutter and
all, you've got a whole
generation of people in their
30s and 40s coming to power.
They're going to be
making choices.
But I don't have a crystal
ball on it.
Can I ask you guys a question?
If I can cold call on it,
why are you here?
I mean, I'm thrilled to see
you, but why are you here?
You've got nothing
better to do?
Get a break?
Or startups in the
Middle East?
I mean, why are you here?
AUDIENCE: It's interesting.
JONAH BERGER: Why?
AUDIENCE: Well, I might be a
little [INAUDIBLE] but I'm on
the localization team
here, and I
studied in Amman in college.
So it's something I'm
very interested in.
JONAH BERGER: So you've
met these people.
You know.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was actually
wondering, because I studied
there, I went to University of
Jordan for a time in college.
And most of the people I
interacted with came from
incredibly wealthy backgrounds
who are in university.
At most of these conferences are
people college educated,
in the university background?
Or are you really seeing more
of the common people getting
engaged in want to pursue it?
JONAH BERGER: You know, as
across the board, and, I
think, I can't prove this, too,
somewhat chronological.
Meaning it is not surprising
that young people have been
gotten a very good education and
have had the resources to
experiment with technology.
And I think, as importantly, if
parents who are willing to
let them take risks so they know
where things are going,
is very powerful.
Someone who read my book said,
main, did all these guys study
in the West?
And in fact, I interviewed
over 200 startups.
And I could only write about 30
of them without losing the
audience totally.
And of that, probably only a
third of them studied in the
West, meaning that they really
were doing things on the
ground a very powerful ways.
So what to me is so exciting at
these gatherings is you do
see the wealthy.
You do see Western educated.
And you see everybody
from everywhere who
is with their devices.
And they are like,
this is cool.
We can make it happen.
So I believe that you'll
see some action from
folks who have that.
And then they start
giving it back.
I love this one great
entrepreneur Samih Toukan.
Did you meet him at all when
you were in Jordan,
or hear about him?
So he was the founder of
Maktoob, which was the first
big exit over there, the Yahoo
of the Middle East.
And what did he do?
Which has happened
100 times here?
He could've taken his
money and run.
He could have done
what ever he did.
He formed something
called Jabbar.
A lot of the best entrepreneurs
from that
company went out to form
other companies.
Souk.com used to
be part of it.
And with Jabbar, he's funding
startups all over the place.
And the stars of his management
team are now
starting other stuff.
And they, trust me, they
come from everywhere.
So that's the cycle that if, in
fact, it happens at scale,
I think changes everything.
Why are you here?
AUDIENCE: I have two
[INAUDIBLE].
One was I read about the stuff
at week end happen in Gaza, a
really interesting
article about it.
It was the first time I
considered startups as a path
to peace and a path
to creating a
more progressive world.
I've always seen startups as
a way of allowing people--
like, the way that we do
startups now, a way of
allowing anybody to
create a business.
But not necessarily, I've
always seen social
entrepreneurship, but never
something that has quite such
a big political change
as well.
So I'm really interested
to find out your
viewpoints on that.
And then, the other thing was,
I've often found that,
generally, the best ideas come
from desperate times.
I think now, like, in the West,
I think everyone, akin
to sort of like empires,
everyone has just gotten used
to being a certain way.
And it's only when, life is at
its worst that actually real
innovation happens.
JONAH BERGER: I couldn't
agree with you more.
AUDIENCE: I definitely think
that, like, as you were saying
this, I literally just wanted
a list of all the great
startups that you were talking
about, I wanted to go through
each of them and see all these
things that we could bring in,
whether it's bringing to Google,
or starting, I always
wanted to start my own
company as well.
So the idea of taking these
great ideas and, I think, one
of the things you pointed out
was a lot of these companies
beforehand had taken ideas
from the West and had
localized them to a point
with [INAUDIBLE].
I think now we're starting to
get to point where there's so
much great startups that we're
going to see a reversal of
people taking the great ideas
from these emerging markets
and starting to move
back over.
JONAH BERGER: You've asked so
many unbelievably exactly
right questions about some of
the stuff that's going on.
And by the way, in the book, and
I think we're handing them
out to you guys on your way
out, I have a list in my--
I have very long people
criticize me, I have a very
long list of thank yous.
I actually listed every company
that I spoke with,
whether they are in
the book or not.
So it's actually a very easy
guide for you to look at least
some of the-- and remember, it's
only a fraction of the
folks that are out there.
And I have friends who are
pissed off because they're not
in there at all.
I mean, that's kind of
the nature of things.
And that's my fault,
not theirs at all.
So I think it's a very
powerful thing.
And I think the ideas that you
do independently, or to think
about your role in Google, is
very, very profound here
because it's, the impact, as I
suggested before, is great.
The second just quick thing that
I would say is I actually
spent-- it was some of the more
interesting interviews
that I did, I've interviewed my
buddies in Silicon Valley.
Because I effectively wanted
to ask them, I'm like, you
invented this stuff, for all
intents and purposes.
How are you thinking about the
world for the next 10 years,
as opposed to last 10 years?
And what was amazing to me is
that a lot of them are still
thinking about it in a framework
of the last 10
years, meaning, well, we'll
invest in an emerging market
if the market cap is so big.
We'll lose our ass in China.
But it's so big, we've got to
be there, so we'll be there.
Second, we definitely are going
to outsource cheaply.
And OK, fine.
I mean, that's fine.
But then I said, do you
understand that you have a new
generation of folks who are
now innovating, right?
And they're not just innovating
for local markets.
I mean, sometimes they are.
Sometimes they are doing stuff
which are very, very local.
And they are going to be very
nice little businesses, and
they're making impact.
Other stuff will be 350
million people.
Other stuff will be emerging
market to emerging market.
And we're going to be using
stuff made in Mina in the next
three years and just think about
it as a way of course.
So how are you thinking
about that?
And often, the answer was, well,
if they're that good,
and that innovative, we'll
convince them to come to
Silicon Valley--
which is a very 10 years
back kind of a thing.
Look, Silicon Valley, it's easy
to try to poke fun at it.
But it's an amazing, I mean,
it's, like, in world history,
like Florence, I mean there
have not been a lot of
geographic locations that have
just put together this network
effect of unbelievable
talent, right?
So I don't want to-- with all
the hubris that we also know
about, I don't want to take
away one iota of that.
But the world is changing.
A lot of people ask me, what is
the Silicon Valley of the
Middle East, and I saw, it's
the wrong question.
There's one Silicon Valley.
Now there are going to be lots
and lots of hubs of really,
really interesting innovation.
How are we going
to get into it?
to support it?
And how are we going
to co-author it?
This is, to me, in some
respects, the most important
thing because if you're over
there, no one liked me for our
government, OK?
But they loved Steve Jobs.
They love Sergei and Larry.
And they'd love to connect with
them, but as co-authors.
They don't want anybody patting
them on the head.
I mean, the most offensive
line--
and this is usually coming
from the government.
Every so often, I've heard
private equity investors use
it, but not anymore.
But they'll say the greatest
American export is
entrepreneurship.
And the folks are like, are
you out of your mind?
We've been entrepreneurs
for 10,000 years.
I mean, so there is an
engagement of co-authorship
of, you know lots of stuff
I'm never going to know.
And it's not just about
your markets.
I mean, think about it .
These are, as I said before,
mobile first societies.
Do you think maybe they've got a
few things to teach us about
mobile that we're not
thinking about?
So it is a real sense
of co-authorship.
It's really a sense that we have
things that we can bring
to bear that might of use.
You've got things to
bring to bear.
And now we're two seconds
away on a device.
Let's see if we can do stuff.
And people are beginning
to get it.
So I don't know if you guys have
done a stuff with McClure
and the 500 startup people.
But he does what he does.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
do what they do.
It's really interesting.
But he also has this thing
called geeks on a plane, where
they just get people to get on a
plane and go see other parts
of the world.
His next trip, in November,
is going to be
in the Middle East.
That never would've been talked
about two years ago.
AUDIENCE: So you've spoken a lot
about, like, these are the
questions that are coming up.
How do you envisage the world,
the Silicon Valley v2, of the
very fact of like a world that
is made of, almost, most
people will become self-made
people working in either a
startups that they created or
are working on a small startup
with a small group of people.
How do you view the world being
with everybody having
the power at their laptop to
start and do whatever they
want to learn whatever
they want?
JONAH BERGER: So I'm old
enough to appreciate
revolutions and also appreciate
entropy, right?
I mean, we're still
sitting here.
And not to take a shot at
YouTube, who does amazing
stuff in the region by the--
we're still talking about 30
second ads in front of
three minute videos.
I mean, stuff doesn't,
everything, change overnight.
So Silicon Valley is
going to be a force
in any kind of sense.
And the way they do business
will be highly successful for
many women and men in many,
many different ways.
The amount of innovation,
because of the ecosystem that
is the United States, isn't
going away any time soon, no
matter what people
like to say.
So there are things that exist
now that are going to exist,
and if you and I have a beer
three years from now.
But what is also going to happen
is that we're going to
be shocked by innovation that
comes from different
parts of the world.
And we're going to be shocked
when, all of the sudden, these
products are serving 2 billion
people markets, and it has
nothing to do with us at all.
And so, again, it's not unlike
what describing what I said--
both will be true, but the
opportunity lies, I would
suggest, much more
interestingly, mutually, in
the second part of it.
Why are you here?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: That's a
good question.
My longtime interest and
graduate study research all
had to do with forced migrants
and displaced
people in East Africa.
And actually, have had to do
with, basically, the effect of
being displaced on a creative
music process.
JONAH BERGER: Wow, meaning
what exactly?
More creativity because of it?
AUDIENCE: So my dissertation was
on, basically, Palestinian
hip-hop music and comparing
musicians in Gaza and the West
Bank, as well as Israeli
citizens, and
Palestinians in a sense.
So the 48s, as well as a band
that were British citizens and
Palestinians.
And analyzing different bands,
basically, the limitations on
being able to collaborate due
to physical limitations--
bands not actually being able
to travel, being stopped at
the border, and then the role of
the internet being able to
promote their own music and the
idea of the end of music
as a way to promote peace over
violence as a way of
expression.
So through that, I also have
an interest in how being
displaced, or being a refugees,
in particular, the
setting of a refugee camp, and
what can be done [INAUDIBLE].
There's a lot of interesting
things happening right now in
refugee camps in terms of
learning trades, and
education, how that happens,
limitations on resources.
And I'm interested in, for
entrepreneurs who are
displaced, and are in those
situations, Syrian refugees,
how it has an influence on
their creative process.
Does it stop it?
How do they continue to, in
particular, I don't think
there's many out there.
But I'd be interested in
startups ideas in refugee
camps themselves.
How can you, in very limited
time constrained, space
constrained settings have a
productive environment that
also sustains people?
JONAH BERGER: You guys have just
asked the best questions
and had the most amazing
experiences.
I'm blown away.
Just a couple of observations,
for what it's worth.
And it ties, one part question
that you asked, and I don't
think I addressed it, because
sometimes this is a
particularly--
you know, I live on an airplane,
but I'm based in
Washington.
So a lot of times, people
ask me, is this part
of the peace process?
Or could it be part of
the peace process?
And I come at it a little bit
differently, meaning that,
when you're able to see a
future, and attain a future,
if you're able to sit with
someone or be connected to
someone, and you'll see that
you share much more than
you're opposed to.
As to, as I said before,
particularly in the case of
entrepreneurs, but I'm sure it
must be the case with artists,
when you speak a language which
is unique to yourself by
the activity that you
do, peace will come.
You are at peace with yourself,
and you're at peace
with the people around you, and
you can see a future that
you can actualize, you tend to
be a more peaceful person.
And so I don't look at
it is as a thing
to be jammed through.
And I can tell you that,
particularly now, I know some
great Palestinian entrepreneurs
who could
probably benefit by connections
to [INAUDIBLE]
because of technology,
skill in Israel,
is just a mind blow.
But it just, all of the sudden,
the very act of that,
right now, today, almost
politicizes it.
And they're like, we're
about building.
No politics now, right?
No religion.
No politics.
Let's build.
But that doesn't mean that, one
day, it couldn't open up
in a very exponential way
as people get to do it.
So that's sort of the way that
I think about it in terms of
the framing of it.
I call to your attention, if
you write it down on your
mobile device or whatever, this
amazing woman named Nina
Curley, C-U-R-L-E-Y, is the
editor in chief of another
amazing enterprise called
Wanbda.com, which if you guys
don't go to, you should go.
Wanbda.com--
and the founder is a great
Lebanese entrepreneur who gets
ticked off when I say it, but
it's the best way I could do
it by analogy-- is sort
of like Tech Crunch.
I mean, it's like the definitive
portal of content
of what's happening in the
ecosystem over there.
But it's much more than that.
It's a social community where
people can share ideas and
best practices, the resources
that you can get there.
They hold events, usually
smaller unconferenced events,
or they have this thing called
mix and mentor where they
bring together people who have
been there with young people.
And they can brainstorm and
do that kind of stuff.
Anyways, Nina is the
editor of content.
And she did this amazing piece
where she interviewed Syrian
expats who escaped with their
lives, effectively, and I
think they're in Dubai now, and
how they think about their
experience, and what they've
learned, how they're keeping
their creativity alive, and
how they're counting the
minutes to be able to go back.
And it was in the "Washington
Post" about two weeks ago.
So if you Google it,
it's very findable.
And it's really moving.
And it's really provocative.
And it falls right into
the category that
you're thinking about.
All I would tell is a couple
things is that, I mean, the
hunger is just a mind blow.
So I don't know if this is still
happening now, but I can
tell you that, less than a year
ago, there are amazing,
amazing engineers in Damascus
who literally snuck--
I was going to write about them,
but I realized I might
put them in jeopardy
by writing about
them, so I never did.
But they literally would sneak
over the border to have
quarterly meetings with
their Beirut partners.
And then, in between, whenever
they could find access to a
proxy server, they did.
And when they could find
broadband, they did.
And if not, if they found
electricity, they would do.
And they just don't stop.
And this Oasis 500 that you
mentioned, which is an
incubator in Jordan, has these
amazing sessions of
training and so on.
They are amazing.
But guess what happens.
They're based in Jordan
for Jordan.
And folks in Ramallah hear about
it, and they are like,
come to Ramallah.
We've got to do this.
Do you do it here?
And can we send some people?
All of a sudden, a bunch
of Syrians show up.
They say, can we participate
also?
Because that's the kind
of hunger and the
appetite that's there.
And I don't think that
gets stifled.
I think it just almost gets
magnified in a broader sense
of mission, as well as a passion
of what they do.
In terms of the refugee camps,
I don't know the answer to
that with precision.
But what I can tell you is
that when people have
technology, they do unbelievable
things.
So one of the most amazing group
of entrepreneurs I met
anywhere were these
five young women--
I feel like I'm rambling,
so forgive me.
But it's cool stuff.
Anyways, so there's this thing
called INJAZ Al-Arab, which is
based, a little bit, on junior
league, I think.
But anyhow, they do
entrepreneurship classes all
over the Middle East.
That's their purpose in
life, for Arab-based.
And I think a million or two
million kids have been through
their programs in elementary
school and high school.
And they may have 30,000 a year,
or something like that,
directionally, who do
these programs.
So every year, they have big
startup competition, the best
of the best high school kids.
And so the five young women in
Yemen learned that one of the
biggest problems in a tent
community near them was that
because that because
of kerosene
lanterns, there were fires.
And they said, well,
this is ridiculous.
There should be solar panels.
They should all have little
devices that are chargeable.
And they can have
light that way.
Why would anybody use
kerosene lanterns?
So their high school project, it
took them 10 months, was to
build sure charging stations
with solar panels and to get
distribution of these electrical
lanterns to this
community, which they did.
All right, unbelievable in and
of itself, but it gets better.
So one of the judges, I was
there, asked these amazing
young kids, they just said, wow,
but what where did you
get the solar panels, right?
Did some NGO give them to you?
The UN give them to you?
How'd you get them.
I get what you put together.
And you really did a great
system integration here, but
where did you get the
solar panels?
And they didn't skip a beat.
They said, well,
we built them.
And they are like, what do
you mean you built them?
They said, oh, yeah, yeah, there
are these great videos
on YouTube-- this is where
you guys come in.
And if you search around-- you
know, it took a while.
But there are literally, if you
search effectively solar
panels, materials, at
home, there are all
these ways to do it.
And it took them 10 months
to do it, but
they figured it out.
And they built like little
solar panels to put in
umbrellas so that people could
have fans in the heat, and
that kinds of stuff.
These are 16-year-old--
five 16-year-old girls
in Yemen, OK?
So that's not quite the refugee
camp analogy, except
that they found a way to bring
something to bear in what is
equivalent to those
circumstances there.
There's in Egypt, but I also an
amazing version of this in
Uganda, folks that are using
texting capabilities to report
things like sexual violence,
which is
unbelievably important.
And then I remember the
entrepreneur saying, I think
I'm a journalist.
I never meant to be
a journalist.
I thought this was a service.
But I'm getting all this insight
and stories that's
helpful to the community about
what's happening on
a day to day basis.
And so I haven't seen,
specifically, examples like
that coming out.
But they certainly are in the
kinds of circumstances that
would talk to what you're
talking about.
I think I've taken
a lot of time.
AUDIENCE: What is the real world
potential of a landscape
changing piece of tech or app
coming out of the Middle East.
And should that happen, like a
Twitter or a Facebook coming
out of this development?
And should that happen?
How does that affect the sort of
Western civilization of the
modern landscape
of technology.
JONAH BERGER: The Western
centralization, from a
structural prospective, like
the success breeds success
ecosystem that I talked about in
terms of Silicon Valley, I
think, wherever great innovation
comes from, still
will have a sense of that
structurally, physically, and
realistically, right?
But where I think the impact is
so profound is in psyche,
both in terms of folks here but,
frankly, with folks on
the ground.
I cannot tell you how much
success breeds success is
important anywhere, but has a
particular power in emerging
growth markets.
When Maktoob went public, it
just changed the whole--
I mean this was $2 million
exit, $175
million, whatever it was.
And it just changed-- there were
just a whole generation
of kids who said, oh my god,
we can do it here.
And when these kids got Mubarak
to fall, they all
looked at each other and said,
oh my god, we can do-- my
parents were wrong.
We could do this kind
of a thing.
So it has this kind of
multiplier effect that's very,
very powerful.
So for example, if this young
woman really does have the
definitive goggle of swim
training, I can't describe to
you not only the multiplier
impact there, but then folks
over here say, well, we should
be distributing that.
Oh, of course, we need to be
thinking about this in a
different kind of a way.
Put it another way.
If we were sitting here in this
room 20 years ago, 10, 20
probably, and I said to you that
the biggest, or among the
biggest player in gaming, and
consumer electronics, and in
mobile, structural devices, were
Korea, Japan, Finland,
we'd look at each other
and say, what
are you talking about?
And things like that then take
on a life of their own if they
continue to scale and continue
to have, I think power.
But the biggest paradigm shift,
which is so stunning to
me, that people across
generations and across
geography still seem to have a
problem really coming to terms
with is this construct that it
can happen anywhere because
the tools are now available.
And the thing that I think
sometimes we don't focus on,
and again, this is where my age
comes in a little bit to
it is, I mean, I remember when
there was a lot of great
technology, but a lot of it
didn't work that well.
I mean, it really works now,
unbelievably, easily, and
well, and accessible.
And when that happens,
then it changes
everything that you're asking.
Thanks for asking that.
Thank you guys for spending
time with me.
It's really been a treat.
If I can be helpful
to you in anyway.
If any of you, they've got
my contact information.
If you ever go to the region,
you have to ping me because I
know a lot of really fun,
interesting people who would
kill to do it.
Take a look at what
McClure is doing.
If you can take time off
and go over, I would
encourage it deeply.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]